Demon's what images are conjured into
your mind when you hear that word in
ancient Greece demons were thought of in
two ways the word demon could be used to
refer to an inner attendant or an
inspiring force in fact the famous
philosopher Socrates said that he lived
his life in accordance with the internal
dictates of his own quote demon
[Music]
in Socrates's view demons were more akin
to what we would refer to as the soul
the other view of demons in ancient
times was that they were being somewhere
in between humans and gods these demons
were not necessarily considered to be
malevolent in the ancient Greek view
demons were thought to be benign similar
in nature to the gods and humans so
widely varied they were nature spirits
forces of nature spirit guides the
rising prominence of Christianity would
change the way demons were thought of
considerably the modern view paints
demons as personifications of wickedness
and malevolence demons today are
typically thought of to be sources of or
agents of evil demons can also be viewed
metaphorically in the modern sense and
the metaphoric sense there is usually
still a negative connotation for example
a person might refer to their own mental
anguish relating to past trauma as inner
demons in this video we will discuss
various literal and metaphorical demons
in a Song of Ice and Fire using both the
archaic and modern definitions
[Music]
considering the ancient definition of
the word both the children of the forest
and the others could potentially be
considered demons the children of the
forest which Martin based on the she of
Irish mythology fill the roles of nature
spirits guardians of the forest the
children are neither good nor evil the
others are also spirits of nature the
personification of winter it would
follow that if the children of the
forest are not evil then neither are the
others the nature of the other simply
does not jive with the nature of humans
coexistence does not seem possible that
being said it is important to note that
coexistence between humans and the
children also failed the children were
forced out of their own territory and
driven to almost complete extinction by
mankind this goes along with the theme
that appears throughout the story men
have difficulty living with nature and
instead seek to subdue and control it
that being said the inhabitants of the
world of Ice and Fire would not likely
consider the children to be demons in
their sense of the word there are many
other things that would be considered
demons in A Song of Ice and Fire however
many that even almost conformed to our
own modern view of the word let's take a
look at how demons are viewed within the
isang of Ice and Fire universe according
to Danny's blood riders a made he was a
woman who lay with demons and practiced
the blackest of sorcery in Abrahamic
mythology at the first woman Lilith was
said to have turned her back on God and
her husband Adam refusing to be
subservient she chose instead to lay
with demons and was cursed by God for it
this idea of women who lie with demons
is also common in many myths about
witches in the real world for power they
would become the brides of Satan himself
so the Dothraki view of a meiji a witch
as a woman who has lain with demons
aligns with many historical views on
witches in our own world as I mentioned
earlier demons are typically thought of
as sources or agents of evil
if gods were beings of benevolence than
demons would be the antithesis this
viewpoint does seem to be present in the
isang of ice and fire world the idea of
a demon is met with a negative
connotation demons in A Song of Ice and
Fire like in our own world are also
sometimes associated with Hell in a
Clash of Kings Arya wonders if roars and
biter were in fact not men and all and
in fact were demons that had been called
up from some Hell by Jack and Hagana
here you can see demons in the Song of
Ice and Fire universe are associated
with Hell so since so many of our real
world views on demons come from
Christianity we have to consider that
perhaps some of the views of the
Westerosi on demons arose from their own
analogue for Christianity which is of
course the faith of the seven this
religion which was brought to Westeros
by the Andals claims that there are both
seven heavens and seven hells descending
deeper and deeper
these hells were a place where sinners
would be punished the idea of layered
hell is reminiscent of the way the
Christian hell is portrayed in Dante's
Divine Comedy an epic poem that tells
the tale of a man journey through hell
and limbo and into heaven eventually
Dante's Inferno is the first cantika of
the Divine Comedy which totally changed
the way Christians viewed hell from that
point on
giving them a visceral view of what hell
may have been like Botticelli's painting
published 150 years later provided an
even more vivid picture depicting humans
being tortured by beings that could only
be described as demons like in our own
world throughout the world of A Song of
Ice and Fire demons are pretty much
always associated with malice corruption
and supernatural evil places that have
been deemed cursed are said to be demon
haunted there is also mention of human
dealings with demons which are always
looked negatively upon here are some
examples the smoking sea where Valyrian
met its doom was mentioned to be demon
hunted in a storm of sorts and a Clash
of Kings very says this to Tyrion when
his
arriving the circumstances of his
mutilation was it a god a demon some
conjurer's trick I could not tell you
and I know all the tricks all I can say
for certainty is that he called it and
it answered and since that day I have
hated magic and all those who practice
it
far north beyond the wall it was said
that Craster who we would later discover
gave his sons to the others quote
trafficked with slavers and demons the
magic of the others is actually referred
to multiple times as demonic in the
first book a game of rooms in a Jon Snow
chapter after the Lord Commander is
attacked by the undead corpse of a
former night's watchman it is stated
that whatever demonic force moved Oh
Thor had been driven out by the flames
and then there are the number of strange
entities set to be worshipped in many
queer places throughout their world
kejoro's Black Goat of the woods which
takes its name from Lovecraftian Bor the
pale child back Alon who was worshiped
in the Dark City of a shy and even rule
or the red God was considered to be a
demon by some like the gods of A Song of
Ice and Fire there are many demons
worshipped revered and feared and also
like the gods their existence can never
truly be verified only hinted at except
considering the children and the others
of course and then there are the
metaphorical demons
[Music]
take Arya Stark for example she was
present at her own father's unjust
execution ripped away from her family
and all that she had ever known forced
to take on other identities like re or
weasel in order to survive but who is
she on the inside
what is she becoming and what has she
become how do our is inner demons
manifest there's no doubt that they
exist and they grow as the books
continue and as traumatic things
continue to happen to Arya who let's not
forget is still a child
Arya makes her first kill in a game of
Thrones before Ned is executed
she had reacted out of terror using
needle to kill a stable boy who had
intended to take her to Queen Cersei
Arya does in fact fill guilt in this
moment it mentions that she fills the
need to get far away from the stables
away from the boys accusing eyes it is
also mentioned that at this point Arya
was still frightened in the face of
death
the next time Arya kills it is much more
deliberate and it does not have nearly
as much of an effect on her by that
point during her escape from Harrenhal
Arya has developed a coldness she kills
the guard in order to escape without any
remorse but remember this is after her
father's unjust execution after the
death of her friend Lommy and the
butcher's boy after being taken prisoner
and beaten Arya at this point is very
traumatized life in general has become
less valuable to her and this only
intensifies Arya's past trauma her
demons are contributing to the formation
of a very dark character Arya's past
trauma her demons manifest in deadly
ways throughout the series in the winds
of winter chapter mercy for instance we
see a version of Arya previously not
seen one that is willing to use
sexuality to lure and then coldly kill
someone who had wronged her in the past
I have said before that I find Aria Sark
in the books to be one of the most
disturbing with all that has happened to
her there's almost no way that she could
grow up without carrying tremendous
baggage with her and Aria is not the
only one
sandor clegane carries his trauma his
demons from his past within him it
manifests in his love of killing and his
fear of fire and perhaps there was
always some seed of cruelty within
Cersei but the witch's prophecy
certainly shaped the decisions that she
made this leads to her paranoid and
delusional behaviors arya was greatly
traumatized by several things but for
many all that takes is a single moment
to permit the entrance of a demon Ned
was tormented throughout book one by his
demons eaten alive by a secret that he
dared not utter allowed the young
graduate ORN his home as a boy and was
thrust into a world that he did not
recognize taken in by the Starks but
always knowing that he was not one of
them and never would be and the
rejection of his true family only
strengthened his demons no character in
this series is free from demons they
manifest in their own hatred of others
and of themselves they manifest in their
fears and doubts George RR Martin's
writing is brilliant because his
characters feel real in this way
none are perfect and all struggle with
some demon supernatural or otherwise
thank you guys so much for watching if
you enjoyed this video make sure you
like and subscribe
and if you want to support this channel
consider clicking the link in the
description to my patreon page